tu l'attends j'ai fait 302 collège latin
trois ans de nathan au collège allait
super m'a dit moi je te dis pas bien
cette diane a fait 312 l'acteur collège
bonjour à tous on va revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé pour moi en 2018 est une
année assez dingue avec plein de gros
projets et à la fin va aussi parler de
ce qui va se passer pour 2010 9 re
déroule on l'a laissé partir on commence
l'année avec le top 10 des jeux de
l'année 2010 cette voie là c'est le
petit clip qu'on a essayé d'instaurer
avec lui car je suis un peu dans le rap
game c'est pas vrai du tout on va bien
évidemment essayer de faire un top 10
des jeux de l'année 2018 ce sera sur la
chaîne big horn des coquillages et on
arrive au premier gros gros gros projet
sur ma chaîne de l'année c'est le court
métrage lunaire été réalisée par raphaël
des cracks on a écrit l'histoire
ensemble c'était fou voilà c'était
plusieurs jours de tournage c'était un
peu le premier court métrage un petit
peu dramatique aussi je suis très
content de ce court métrage l'arrêt de
la diffusion en avant-première dans une
salle de cinéma au max linder à paris
c'était absolument dingue de pouvoir
vous projetez ce court métrage dans des
conditions pareilles je suis ravi de ce
projet de toutes les collaborations et
de ce que ça raconte parce qu'en fait
c'est en tout cas c'est intime c'est une
relation fraternelle que j'ai un petit
peu vécu que j'ai mis dans cette
histoire là et merci aussi à tous les
fans art
on a eu plein de petits dessins assez
fou sur sur ce court métrage l'a donc je
pense que l'année commence plutôt bien
pour provisionner si l'envié vous en
prend avec un bouton ici qui s'affiche
on repart ensuite sur du sketch un petit
peu plus classique que c'est l'invention
corps humain mais avec du guest de
qualité adam foresti nous a fait un
petit peu la patronne des réunions de
conception du monde elle était géniale
est venu à eau répète elle a écrit avec
no mercy florence merci à allison à
julia à mc fly j'espère que ce sketch
vous a plu et peut-être une aura
d'autres qui s'est close en parlant de
langues étrangères à mon sketch les
langues étrangères
si la chine qui a participé à cette
vidéo notamment une chaîne youtube c'est
bien pourquoi ne pas en avoir une
deuxième c'est pour ça qu'on a relancé
avec lucas cyprien gaming que vous
connaissez maintenant sous le nom de
bigorneaux et coquillages on a tout
remis en question sur cette chaîne là on
fait un peu moins de gaming
il est vrai mais on fait plus de petits
délires et surtout d'un nouveau studio
on a fait plein de petits concept de
la con du genre ont fait des tours de
magie on teste des véhicules de merde
voilà en tout cas c'est une chaîne nous
nous amuse énormément faut juste trouver
du temps pour pouvoir faire des vidéos
ça c'est le plus compliqué parce qu'on
est des gens occupés on était youtuber
il ya plein de nouvelles vidéos prévu
pour les grands des coquillages pour
l'année 2010 neuf donc vous pouvez
rejoindre la chaîne bien évidemment
d'ailleurs je parle souvent de fanart
mes yeux plein de fans sont incroyables
sur big renault et coquillages merci à
tous ceux qui ont participé dans tes
pensées qu'on a sorti une petite
boutique en ligne avec des produits au
big one et coquillages qui s'appelle
crustacés et tous nos bénéfices revend à
l'association c'est que du bonheur qui
oeuvrent pour le quotidien des enfants
dans les hôpitaux
donc voilà si vous voulez être crustacés
comme jamais vous avez le lire dans la
description et c'est ça aide aussi les
enfants de résoudre un court métrage
c'est bien gentil
pourquoi pas un deuxième et c'est là
qu'on arrive à mon second court métrage
de l'année 2018 qui est décidément un
alien qui est un court métrage très
particulier pour moi parce qu'en fait
les a été écrit assez rapidement voilà
c'est un peu comme une grosse blague
mais avec beaucoup de préparation des
dessins préparatoires sur la lienne il a
été construit pendant des semaines
repérer des lieux on a aussi un cast
incroyable avec les enfants isabelle
nanty on est à l'opposé de l'unr puisque
lunaire c'est un truc un petit peu
cérébrale là on est dans du bon gros
débile de vie qui a été parfait à la
réalisation là dedans d'ailleurs un gros
gros qui est j'ai adoré incarner un
rasta blanc a oui je veux dire je porte
si bien le bouquet puis j'ai fumé on
promet faux pétards et bientôt 30 ans
pour tester de nouvelles choses et un
faux joint avec du thé à l'intérieur ne
fumez pas trop avec squeeze on part à
los angeles la sangre pour le salon du
jeu vidéo comme chaque année et là on a
fait des petits vlog donc c'était cool
on a fait du surf on a fait plein de
choses on arrive à l'été voilà les gens
posent leurs vacances et moi qu'est ce
que j'ai fait pendant des semaines j'ai
préparé la saison 2 de l'épopée temporel
10 épisodes d'une dizaine de minutes
avec des trucs assez incroyable à
écouter tranquillement les pieds dans
l'eau ou chez vous ou vous
c'était génial de faire bien sûr cette
saison 2 avec encore plus de comédiens
avec encore plus de musique avec mes
auteurs incroyable son avocat yassine et
françois et bien sûr pour terminer cette
deuxième saison on a sorti un coffret
collector avec les deux saisons en cdi
des stickers un livret etc
vous pouvez vous procurer sur un maul
point fr ils sont tous dédicacés parce
que c'est un objet collector il je veux
pas spoiler mais il y aura d'autres
choses autour de l'épopée temporel il
faudra être un petit peu patient se sera
pas nécessairement une série audio je ne
peux pas en dire plus si je pourrai mais
j'ai pas envie c'est je vous laisse un
petit peu la surprise voilà l'épopée
temps pour elles risquent de revenir
sous une forme un petit peu étonnant
quand on arrive à la rentrée en
septembre est large mais ma plus belle
perruque pour le sketch les instagram
heureuse avec audrey pirro voilà c'est
une suite de sketches avec des
influences euse qui essayent de survivre
sous le nom d' influence c'était très
amusant à faire puis avec audrey s'est
très bien passé big up aussi la luciole
qui m'a aidé à écrire les sketchs
d'ailleurs vous pouvez rejoindre les
compte instagram de alice et zoé si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur leur vie pour
venir cette année avec des nouveaux
sketches du court métrage ça va
troisième c'est beaucoup mieux c'est
pour ça qu'on arrive au troisième court
métrage qui s'appelle la science de
l'amour qui a été écrit et réalisé par
timothée hochet et c'est un projet qui
me tient énormément à coeur parce que
c'est le premier projet dramatiques sur
ma chaîne réellement c'est une histoire
de nouvelles technologies et d'amour on
est sur un registre et des thèmes que je
n'aborde jamais sur ma chaîne donc c'est
vraiment de la grosse nouveauté c'est un
peu ça passe ou ça casse mais je me suis
dit peut-être que les abonnés vont pas
trop comprendre en tout cas moi j'ai
adoré faire ce projet là bravo à toute
l'équipe j'étais très très agrément
surpris des retours voilà l'un d'entre
vous qui ont beaucoup aimé que je pense
continuer un petit peu dans cette
direction à créer des histoires de plus
en plus ambitieuses et si vous n'avez
pas pu vous pouvez cliquer juste là pour
découvrir la science de l'amour ou si
regardez le making off plein de petites
astuces qu'on vous monte en avance sur
un nouveau projet qui n'est pas un
projet internet vous avez j'espère
entendu parler de ça mais j'ai sorti à
trois ans ma bande dessinée qui
s'appelle roger et c'est humain
j'ai écrite c'était très nombreux à me
demander la suite ça m'a pris du temps
et voilà début janvier jusqu'à la moitié
de l'année j'ai écrit à la suite de
roger et c'est humain le tome 2 on est
allé encore un peu plus loin dans la
bande dessinée avec plus de pages plus
d' aventure plus de décors plus de
blagues plus de tout pouvez vous la
procurer il ya aussi un coffret avec
deux tomes avec un pas peur toyal
intérieur atteint sur soi même ce genre
de choses je suis très content il ya le
tome 2 mais aussi le dessin animé roger
et c'est humain voilà c'est un format
court où je fais la voix de roger et je
suis très content de bosser dessus et la
suite des épisodes vont arriver cette
année si vous êtes patient pour la
savoir en termes de courts métrages de
tout ça parce qu'elle met pas du tout un
quatrième pour terminer l'année un petit
peu plus court certes mais un court
métrage que j'apprécie particulièrement
puisque c'est moi qu'il est réalisé
entièrement ça s'appelle fait un voeu
c'est très simple c'est juste ce qui se
passe dans la tête d'un petit garçon qui
grandit et voir comment ses rêves évolué
à des blagues à l'intérieur mais pas que
c'est un truc un petit peu complexe que
je voulais raconter depuis un petit
moment comment être fidèle à ses rêves
et en même temps apprendre à évoluer
voilà ça parle de ça et merci beaucoup
pour l'accueil que vous avez fait pour
mon dernier court métrage de l'anfr vous
pouvez visionner ici tout de suite si
vous voulez on s'approche des fans de
fin d'année j'ai fait une petite vidéo
avec bouygues telecom en fait je
reproduis des vieilles photos de moi
enfant toute une équipe pour
reconstruire les décors les costumes
j'ai l'air totalement ridicule est-ce
que c'est pas ça aussi le métier de
youtube heures je vous le demande si
c'est ça et on termine l'année avec le
retour des pubs versus la vie avec un
atout c'est toujours un peu fun à faire
de reproduire des pubs totalement
absurde peut-être qu'il y en aura
d'autres on sépare qu'on s'est passé
c'est la surprise
l'aîné videmment j'ai participé à des
petites vidéos à gauche à droite chez mc
fly carlito je sais on a perdu
il faut arrêter d'en parler ça me
stresse énormément cette histoire de
théâtre et tous ok j'ai fait une
apparition aussi dans une vidéo du
joueur du grenier dans le clip de pom
pom qui a fait la musique de fin du
court métrage lunaire tout est lié on
vous dit pas tout de suite un reptile
hier j'ai aussi participé au téléthon
gaming pour lever des fonds ici je
devais faire un petit bilan de l'année
2018 c'est surtout que j'ai fait des
projets qui me tiennent énormément à
coeur et beaucoup de
court métrage au final j'ai fait huit
courts métrages en tout sur ma chaîne et
en a quatre qui ont été fait cette année
donc je pense que c'est quand même
beaucoup c'est beaucoup de travail
l'investissement mais c'est énormément
de plaisir plein de rencontrer plein de
projets dont je suis très très fier
c'est un peu pour moi une année assez
riche artistiquement on va dire là j'ai
l'impression de voir créer ce qu'il me
plaît tout en faisant aussi des sketches
qui sont plus simples comme les pubs
versus la vie les langues étrangères
faire ce genre de choses sont très fun à
faire mais artistiquement j'aime bien
aussi explorer d'autres choses on arrive
en 2019 quels sont les projets pour
cette année déjà
il va y avoir un jeu mobile voilà ça
fait plus d'un an qu'on travaille dessus
c'est un jeu où tu crées un petit
youtuber et tu dois améliorer un peu ses
vidéos sa chaîne youtube créée plusieurs
chaînes j'espère que ça va vous plaire
voilà moi j'aime bien créer des jeux
aussi vous avez vu le nombre crise par
exemple même ta mère en slip le petit
jeu mobile voilà c'est un truc qui est
vraiment très fun à faire mais c'est
très très très longue demande du temps
strates que ça sorte
voilà vous serez tenu au courant dès que
ça arrivera dévoilera le nom ou le
télécharger tout ça vous inquiétez pas
j'ai participé aussi à des tournages
l'année dernière par exemple la chaîne
internet où ilyes vous aime donc voilà
ces projets là vont arriver cette année
mais quel sera le prochain gros projet
sur ma chaîne youtube et bien c'était un
court métrage forcément pas de surprise
mais qui a une particularité puisqu'il
sera tourné boucle japon à tokyo plus
précisément c'est vraiment un rêve de
faire ça parce qu en fait j'adore ce
pays et j'ai plein de choses à raconter
j'ai écrit l'histoire est en train de
former l'équipe on prépare le tournage
là bas ce sera dans quelques semaines
quelques mois j'ai envie de raconter
plein de choses à l'intérieur parler des
différences entre la france et le japon
mais aussi les rêves d'artistes de tout
ça bref je veux pas vous dévoiler le
scénario mais j'ai très hâte d'y
retourner et de vous le montrer tout
simplement il ya aussi plein de choses
qui vont arriver sur ma chaîne ne sais
pas vous êtes vu la suite des intrigues
rameuses dessins animés roger c'est
humain qui va arriver et plein d'autres
projets et j'ai aussi derrière des trucs
qui sont encore plus fou plus grosse
demande plus de travail et d'argent et
de tout ça mais je peux pas trop trop
vous en parler si un jour vous voyez
d'autres projets qui arrivent c'est
normal c'est parce que je travaille
dessus en tout cas merci beaucoup pour
cette année 2010 8 merci de me suivre et
de me faire confiance dans tous ses
projets et moi j'ai très hâte de faire
plein de choses aussi pour l'année 2019
je vous dis à très vite clap alors par
contre qui
qui dit oui j'y viens en quatre jours on
passe des photos de plage on trouve donc
aux deux fois king tagen a battu voix
j'ai la poisse avec les accessoires
couper cette affiche de hockey ça va oui
petit rongeur
c'est très bien j'ai pas de livre les
enfants
il doit équiper alice à temps et si tu
es pourquoi pas pour les âmes
oui un jour on va le faire ce tour du
monde
consommer un maximum de drogue iaquinta
je crois annonce avant trouve pas qu'on
me l'enlève
je vais jouer à porte avec moi si on
prend la même règle aux mérous bien mais
bon voilà c'est vrai c'est toujours
cette ambivalence que tu as à l'isq et
compliqué à gérer pour les gens autour
un photo quand même quand même raconté
toutes les couleurs vous ne sortez pas
du violet ou plus n'est pas valorisé non
pas du tout non je comprends